hey guys thanks so much for visiting our
YouTube channel I just want to let you
know that we're adding inspiring and
life-changing content on this page all
the time almost every day but that's not
all you can also watch the Dave Ramsey
show live stream live monday through
friday from two to five PM eastern time
right here on our youtube channel page
here's just a little bit of what you
should expect to see slow and steady we
were in dire situation financially live
on less than you may think that the dave
ramsey book has changed our life if
attacked well you can do this i weighed
almost 600 pounds sixty thousand dollars
in debt believe it does happen every day
in America I have lost 400 pounds as
paid off it's kind of like you have a
fist bump moment like a yes they don't
know yes there is no excuse for you to
retire bro the faster you go radical the
faster this mess is going to clean up
do I stop you at all uh maybe if you had
your little stool out there on the
mangoes are
is it paid for with my husband passed
away he was always watching our s that
something has to happen inside of you
you know when you've had it I used to be
a bankrupt if not serve some time in
prison my past was in the past but I
didn't know anybody anymore you are the
answer is unbelievable when finally pop
go subscribe to right now you don't want
to miss out on this then I mention its
wife hey thanks for watching everybody